sembra stia venendo guardano al gira
gira gira guarda tanto sono venute tonde
deliziose ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
puntata di cucina buttata ci troviamo a
giugno in quello che è il mese del pride
per questo che ho deciso di creare una
ricetta che fosse dolce zuccherosa
colorata ma che soprattutto avesse la
possibilità di piantarti si sullo
stomaco e non andarsene via finché non
avrebbe ottenuto i propri diritti
devo dire che ricetta genero non l'ho
detto sto parlando dei donuts americani
quelli col buco per fare le donald's
avremo bisogno di 280 grammi di farina
infinito mezzo cucchiaino di lievito di
birra 130 grammi di succo di book mezzo
25 grammi di su che ho 25 grammi di
lubrificante morbido 5 grammi di
ritenzione idrica idrica liquida di
detenzione a vede sale estratto di
vaniglia e olio per friggere e per
rimanere il sony per le classe avremo
bisogno di zucchero a velo sudore quanto
basta coloranti alimentari in polvere
raga in polvere e infine tanti diversi
confettini da poter spalmare ovunque
fare questa ricetta è facile ma allo
stesso tempo richiede la pazienza del
maestro muten di pai mei che sono in
realtà due maestri che non hanno
minimamente pazienza quale poi si
richiede veramente la pazienza di un
monaco tibetano perché bisogna aspettare
tanto per le limitazioni vi spiego
esattamente quello del procedimento
della ricetta americana quella ufficiale
partiamo subito con lievi tino che ha un
nome
mi sembra più una pratica sessuale
avremo bisogno di unire per 12 ciambelle
più o meno 50 g di farina 50 grammi di
latte le il lievito giriamo ragazzi
uniformiamo tutto quanto quando si fanno
queste preparazioni continuare comunque
a girare la cosa importante è far sì che
ogni singola particella di lievito
ogni centimetro cubo di questo impasto
non è mai capitato di avere tipo le cose
che gli evitavano storte perché non
avete impostato bene
in realtà quando lievitano sport e può
essere anche il problema del forno di
base perché o fate cagare voglio far
pagare la vostra cucina mettiamo la
pellicola ma lo facciamo riposare per
un'ora c'è qualcosa di stranamente vivo
a questo punto andiamo ad aggiungere le
vicino tutti quanti gli altri
ingredienti aggiungere la restante parte
della farina dello zucchero aggiungiamo
una bella aspri manciata di vaniglia
così non proprio bella da vedere giriamo
e aggiungiamo unità d'uovo ora metà
fuoco per poterla fare la sbatte di
noceto di nenè aggiungete metà un po
occhio era di legno suo guscio durissimo
per dove arriva le cose ce le ha messe
dentro come consuetudine no
gianmarco però vedo che tu i tuoi
commenti invece li metti dentro ogni
volta senza problemi girate girate unite
bene raggiungiamo metà fuoco ad occhio
noto così non dovevo pesarlo di e con
una siringa prenderlo non mi fare reader
giriamo tutto quanto e mescoliamo
insieme passiamo a utilizzare un po le
mani anche ma adesso ci aggiungiamo un
po di burro super mollo ragazzi
suggeriscono di aggiungerne poco alla
volta quindi lo aggiungiamo impasta in
tutto quanto quando è assorbito e
aggiungiamo altro poco riguardo subito
track a me queste cose che devi fare uno
alla volta e aspettare che siano già
rotto le palle quindi sto andando a
metterci tutto quanto archico il cazzo
no dai
almeno fallo diviso in tre fasi non ti
si certo se vede una merda ha messo la
quantità sbagliata di latte
una volta un affetto per il burro
diritti del burro il batter pride lo
trasferiscono quello che infilano la
cucina vogliono planetaria frega un
cazzo
secondo me scivolare un altro prima di
latte molto più mondo sappiate che
stiamo lavorando per aprire la stagione
cucina buttata a una cucina folle non
posso dirvi nulla perché se non mi
picchiano mai folle le fosse per me bra
fare vedere adesso il progetto ogni cosa
ha un prezzo
ogni cosa ha un prezzo bisognerà 50.000
like sperando di non arrivarci per una
volta posso dire soltanto di non
arrivarci perché sono poi sono costretto
a farla vedere io sono che è una cucina
che non cucina solo è che non esiste una
cucina simile nel mondo
aggiungo anche un'altra cosa se voglia
di sostenerci per questo nuovo progetto
di cucina buttata che sarà all'interno
di un posto stupendo iscriviti per
questo canale
cosa aspettate alla fine tutto quanto ci
troveremo con questo piccolo cumulo che
metteremo a lievitare anche non
triplicherà di volume io non so se tutta
questa pazienza mi fanno andare in tanto
per le ore poi marco l'arma mie due ore
di lievitazione cosa devo fare
vediamo che succede mai che la allora in
realtà poteva lievitare di più ma già mi
a noi cos'è che pesa da morire il culo
esatto scrivetelo nei commenti e
iniziamo a stenderlo gianni caroti modo
devo farlo avere ragione di un
centimetro
poi ci aiutiamo con un bicchiere è un
tappo
vedete quanto sono green e ora un'ora e
mezza per farle lievitare si domandò ma
non vinceremo un'ora e mezza mentre
aspettiamo che li eviti tutto quanto
passiamo al momento delle classe infatti
si ma siccome siamo sempre giugno è
proprio una giornata importante quella
di oggi mi son detto ma se facessimo la
glassa tutta rainbow la butta in caciara
coi colori
sì sì sì sì ok grazie per questo
sostegno mi sento veramente la classe è
molto semplice zucchero a velo e poca
acqua molto densa ma deve essere densa
perché deve scrivere quando dicono
qualche qualcosa deve scrivere intendono
questo adesso andiamo a mettere in
cinque bicchierini vogliono celebrare
gli stessi cinque colori dell'altra
volta perché sei diventano troppi i
cinque colori per fare questa specie di
sfumatura arcobaleno zza e vado a
dividere quindi il composto in cinque
bicchieri diversi giallo qua altro
giallo qui rosso prende il bouquet
unisco insieme al rosso è pressante
vediamo qualche cosa cielo su giallo
sono un po timidi come colori in queste
è verde nel verde quindi non riesco a
vedere niente è un atto in succede col
rosso wow
ok ragazzi abbiamo finito i colori sono
qui sono molto belli perché abbiamo
fatto un piccolo giochetto abbiamo
utilizzato pochissime gocce anche di
questi coloranti liquidi che eravamo già
dispensa per via del rainbow tosta e
quindi abbia fatto un po un mischione
tra colorante in polvere colorante
liquido in modo da non andare a rovinare
la consistenza originaria della nostra
classe è il documento finalmente di
togliere le nostre ciambelle dal forno
spento e friggerle in tutto questo sto
cercando di capire come fare a fare
quello che voglio fare
ho un'idea ma è molto rischiosa una di
quelle idee che se viene viene
se non viene è un fallimento
un pochino si sono mosse specialmente il
nostro abbacchio è diventato bello
importante sembra stia venendo guardan
gira gira gira vogliamo ricordare la tua
ultima frittura alla violenza no non ha
senso non commettere il consolido errore
della poca cultura del prodotto ma
guarda conto cazzo è cotto quel prodotto
commette il tuo solito ere errore della
critica del programma miqua della
critica del prodotto
a me sembra corrotto c'è stato
pochissimo è appunto quello che mi
perplime presepio di niente questo è qui
che sto girando continuamente sanno
quanto sono venute tonde deliziose alla
fine vi ritroverete con delle
ciambelline così carinissime vogliamo
passare a questo punto la glassa magica
piattino di 23 bassi segui quello che
vado a fare non è andata benissimo ma ci
riproviamo non proprio incredibili non
la devi muovere secondo me ci stai
nascondendo i risultati
stai lavorando nell'oscurità mi sto
nascondendo per evitare di subire delle
critiche però questa qui non è brutta le
trovo più belle quello che pensassi ma
meno quello che volevo e graziosa dai
l'unica critica che ti posso se è che mi
piace molto ma non si percepiscono tutti
i colori
per alcuni però io sono un po daltonici
noi quindi dovete dirlo voi ragazzi se
si vedono i colori perché purtroppo in
questo giudici siamo solamente io
giammarco che in questo diciamo che
abbiamo qualche piccolo malus e variate
alla fine bisogna assaggiare questo
meraviglioso ciambellino mettete un po
le censure sia per sostenere questo
canale che per sostenere questo periodo
di amore universale detto ciò possiamo
all'assaggio ha un po paura
posso fare gianmarco non so non fanno
delle classe c a me quella roba
zuccherata sopra non impazzisco
ma è buona
tanta classe zucchero zucchero
impegnativo ma già toccato mezzo morso
che non so dire la cottura l'hai fatta
bene che mi preoccupavo dello che fosse
caduto ne regge tutto quanto troppo
c'è giusto ragazzi meno male che il
prete tra tramezzini ciambelline
comunque ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video ha come sempre vi
ringrazio per il grande sostegno che
dimostrate
detto ciò se farete queste ciambelline
mi raccomando come col tosta gr temi su
instagram voglio vedere cosa fate un
condividere con i vostri amici questi
centri non ci vediamo domenica prossima
alle 12 con un nuovo cucina buttata ciao